the evening quiet in the west of ukraine
broken by the sound of russian missiles
hitting their target
hours after the attack of fuel storage
facilities still burning smoke still
covering the skies over la viv
the capital ukrainians say may be the
heart of the country but lev with nearly
800 years of history and cultural
heritage is its soul
we personally thought that
they will not touch west ukraine because
they were
targeted mostly to the east ukraine cave
geraldine
and the big cities in the deeper river
now they are
attacking the calculus
heart of ukraine
i think it's terrible we didn't come
here from kiev to hear bombings
it's war it's real war it's terrible
really because people are dying
all our cities perfect cities beautiful
cities are
you know destroyed and
it's time to stop it because it's 21st
century what can we say about it
there is outrage here ukrainians say
they feel betrayed by russia and despise
vladimir putin
[Music]
they are the antichrist ukraine has
never attacked anyone why are they doing
this they don't need the people or land
they don't need anything all they have
is their meaningless ambitions
it's just horror blood death and despair
the roar of a wild horde the tiny grey
man has done a lot of black horrible
evil he's a beast
the west of the country has seen some
high-profile attacks since the russian
invasion began but levi was spared the
worst of the violence
warning sirens likely to be taken more
seriously now
loud thuds and explosions have shattered
the relative calm that leve had been
experiencing throughout this war so far
we've just heard reports that the target
of the attack from which this smoke is
emanating was a fuel depot on the other
side of the city
leve has been at the center of the
country's humanitarian response to the
war the wider region has also been key
as a military hub moments before the
first attack we met with the city's
mayor he says he speaks to his
counterparts coping with the destruction
of their own cities every day
today all cities in ukraine have very
similar situation
i don't know ways
target
next russian missile
but my
my duty this security my citizens and
safe
for
refugees
a job made more difficult with attacks
within lev city limits
as night came more missile strikes
hitting more targets
this is the closest the war has come to
the center of this city
an escalation that brings the war right
to the heart of la viv
zain basravi al-jazeera